65 the effects driven sci-fi movie with
lots of scary dinosaurs is officially
going extinct at the box office stiff
competition could be one reason why
among a whole bunch of other factors
starring Adam Driver and Ariana
Greenblatt 65 is all about Mills KOA and
their Survival on a hostile Planet
populated by dinosaurs these two are the
only ones left after their spaceship
crashes and Mills feels honor bound to
protect the young KOA this means 65 is
great for people who like dinosaurs and
science fiction there's something alien
out there unfortunately it looks like
these people weren't motivated to go to
the movie theaters and 65 has missed the
mark in terms of box office returns
there could be many different reasons
why 65 is going extinct which may
include reviews competition and not a
lot of Star Power released on March 10
2023 65 has faced significant
competition from several different
movies a movie like 65 might already
struggle to bring in audiences but
squaring up against the likes of Scream
6 and Creed 3 hasn't been kind to 65
either the results have been quite
abysmal with 65 making only 12.3 million
dollars at the box office for comparison
Scream 6 earned a respectable 44.5
million dollars the franchise's
strongest debut yet besides the direct
competition from Scream 6 there are many
movies that are still generating income
like Puss in Boots The Last Wish cocaine
bear and Avatar the way of water this
means there are plenty of options when
it comes to enter attainment and it
seems like 65 didn't generate enough
interest to overpower any of the other
choices at the theater in addition to
stiff competition the general critical
consensus around 65 has not been
favorable reviews have not been kind to
65 and Rotten Tomatoes currently has the
movie at a 38 critical score however it
seems like the general audience views
the movie in a slightly more positive
light giving the movie a 63 positive
rating still these results are hardly
glowing and negative word of mouth can
affect box office yields Common Sense
Media wrote while this sci-fi dinosaur
movie is competently made it really only
has one good idea and it doesn't do much
with it the rest is generic familiar and
fails to generate much suspense or
emotion not all critics were unkind to
the movie empire magazine thought the
movie was bold in creating an original
story noting that the film moved at a
Brisk pace and the no-nonsense plot was
buoyed by the occasional Tyrannosaurus
Rex still 65 isn't creating a lot of
positive chatter another facet to
consider is that 65 doesn't have a lot
of star power other than Adam Driver
besides driver the other main star is
Ariana Greenblatt whose biggest claim to
fame at this point is appearing as young
Gamora in Avengers Infinity War driver
is not without his army of dedicated
fans but driver isn't exactly known as
an action star the one exception to this
is the recent Star Wars sequel Trilogy
beyond that however driver usually isn't
running in gunning perhaps that's the
reason why driver decided to join the
cast of 65 as it afforded him something
different at the moment however it seems
as if audiences aren't buying into this
version of the actor another piece of
this puzzle is that 65 is an original
property and not part of a franchise
much like Creed 3 avatar the way of
water and Puss in Boots The Last Wish
considering that 65 was created for
around 91 million dollars it appears as
if the film has quite the uphill
struggle ahead if it wishes to recoup
the invest did Money perhaps 65 will
undergo a massive change of Fate but at
the moment it looks like it's under the
looming shadow of a cataclysmic asteroid